[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدي الكرام
لا للتدخل الخارجي ضد بشار الاسد نعم
الاسود والكيماوي وغاز السارين والمياه
والصخور والبراميل المتفجره
وكل انواع المدفعيه نعمل مليون طفل لا جاء
نعمل ثمانيه ملايين سيده عجوز وشاب نازح
نعمل قتل مئات الالوف من السوريين نعم
لمسح مدن باكملها عن خريطه سوريا نعم
لاعتقال نصف مليون سوري نعمل عائله الاسد
ل مائه عام قادمه
نعم لتدخل الاصدقاء من ايران وحزب الله
ومالك العراق وقطع ان المهدي نعم لدخول
الصديق والجار حزب العمال الارهاب الثاني
نعم لدخول روسيا القوميه العربيه السوريين
هذه او هذا بلدنا ونحن اولى بتدمير ه
هكذا يتحكم احد السوريين في الفيس بوك
اليس حريا بالعالم الاخر اس ان ينقذ ما
تبقى من سوريا من براثن النازيه الجديده
لكن في المقابل ان تزيد الضربه الامريكيه
ان وقعت الدمار في سوريا دمارا
اليس الذين يدعون الى قصف بلدهم متامرين
واخوانا لاوطانهم لماذا لم يتعلموا من
تجربه العراقيين الذين عادوا الى العراق
على ظهور الدبابات الامريكيه
هل يعقل ان الكثير من دول العالم ترفض
التدخل في سوريا بينما يدعو اليه
المعارضون السوريون هل تدخلت امريكا في
بلد الا وكانت عواقب التدخل وخيمه اليس
حريا بالسوريين ان يفضلوا الحوار الوطني
على صعوبته على تحريض الاخرين على وطنهم
من قال ان امريكا جمعيه خيريه
اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه من برلين على المعارضه
السوري حبيب صالح وهنا في الاستوديو على
سيد جوان رشاد عضو النادي الاجتماع السوري
في بريطانيا
النقاش بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدي الكرام نحن معكم
على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل يستحق النظام السوري ضربه
عسكريه ساحقه عقابا له على استخدام اسلحه
الدمار الشامل ضد شعبه صوت على صفحه
الاتجاه المعاكس حول وسبعين الفا سبعه
وثمانون فاصله سبعه نعم اطناش فاصله ثلاثه
وبدات بهذه النتيجه معك استاذ حبيب صالح
سمعنا في برلين استاذ حبيب صالح نعم لو
بدات معك بهذه النتيجه اه بس دقيقه دقيقه
واحده ثلاث السؤال اجريت مثل هذا
الاستطلاع او هذا الاستفتاء في عام الفين
وثلاثه قبل الغزو الامريكي للعراق
هل تؤيد ضربه عسكريه للنظام العراقي فكانت
النتيجه في عام الفين وثلاثه
حوالي تسعين بالمائه من الشارع العربي لا
ضد الضربه اليوم الامر معكوس تماما سبعه
وثمانون فاصله سبعه مع ضربه ساحقه ماحقه
لنظام بشار الاسد ماذا تقول
ببساطه متناهيه كانت ضربه ضد العراق ضربه
ضد موقف سياسي للقياده العراقيه
وكانت المقصود بها ازاحه العراق من اطار
التوازن الخليجي القائم بينه وبين ايران
وما ان خرج العراق حتى اصبحت ايران
امبراطوريه
الموضوع الموضوع الموضوع السوري بدو
التاريخيه اما في الموضوع السوري فهناك
الكيماويات
تكاد تكون قضايا الساعه في العالم هناك
خبراء الامم المتحده هناك اه اه اه طبعا
ال الولايات المتحده هناك المخابرات
الفرنسيه هناك تقارير الائتلاف الوطني
السوري هنا هناك تقارير الكتائب وال وال
والالويه المتموضعه في اماكن الاصابه هناك
عشرات الاف الاصابات التي وقعت في صفوف
الشوارع ما يظهر ويؤكد ويثبت ويقطع ان
النظام هو الذي اطلقها لان كل ضحاياها
كانوا من الشوارع وكانوا من المعارضين ولا
نعرف ان منطقه ما اصيبت وكان بها اه من من
ادوات النظام وبالتالي كل الضحايا كانوا
في الجانب الاخر المعاديه للنظام والسير
على النظام هذا يدل على ان مصدر الاطلاق
كان مصدر النظام ومصدر الاطلاق كان جنود
النظام والى اخره الى الجهاد ايضا مباشره
الامم المتحده
الموضوع
لماذا يستحق الضربه انه يستحق الضربه لسبب
واحد اولا لسنوات استخدم فيها كل اله
الحرب التدميريه ضد الشعبيه هذه اولا ثم
ثانيا لانه خرج على كل اشي وروحي وقضايا
الشرعيه الدوليه التي حرمت استخدام اسلحه
الدمار الشامل
وحرمت استخدام الكيماوي وحرمت
ورغم ذلك ورغم ذلك وهناك طبعا اللجان التي
اثبتت ذلك وهناك
الامم المتحده
المحاضره هون قلت المحاضره هذه نحنا في
المحافظه كيف ترد على هذا الكلام سبعه
وثمانين بالمائه سبعه وثمانين بالمائه
فاصله سبعه اه من المصوتين حوالي سبعين
الفا مع ضربه ساحقه ماحقه للنظام السوري
ماذا تقول لهم من قبل مرض على اه سؤالك
اسمح لي ان اتوجه بالرحمه على كل الشهداء
السوريه الطاهرين الابرار سواء كانوا من
المعارضه ومن الموالاه سواء كانوا من
المدنيين ومن العسكريين الرحمه على سوريا
والشفاء لكل الجرحى والمصابين يعني صراحه
الكلام اللي عم يحكي اخى و صديقى الحبيب
للطرف الاخر كلام مضحك يعني ردا على
واحترامي على النسبه لل ذكرت هي حاليا
الاعلام المزور المفرق الحقائق يعني
الاطفال اللي عملوا سته وسبعه حاليا
بيضحكوا على احصائيات الجزيره
خلينا
الفين وثلاثه وعشرين نفس الاستفتاء لماذا
كان عكس ذلك
ماشي الحال لانه ب الفين وثلاثه والفين
واربعه التزوير الاعلامي والغش عن طريق
الجزيره واخواتها ومشتقاتها ما كانت
بالطريقه هاي خليني خليني ارد على السؤال
نعم الاخ الكريم عم بيقولوا هنالك تقارير
امريكيه و ثبوتيات وموثقه يعني سبحان الله
يعني عم بياكد انه كلام مسلمه الكتاب كلها
تذكر الله ما طرح كولين باول على
ورفع ال الانبوب قالها اسطوانه ال السلاح
العراقي سلاح التدمير الشامل اذا ما جمع
العراق العالم كله في خطر شو طلع طلع
مسلمه الكذب نفسه كولين باول قال يا جماعه
انا كتبت عليكم خلينا نرجع عن سوريا يعني
بالله عليك واحد يعني يا اخي بالله عليك
الجيش العربي السوري يتقدم على طول
الجغرافيه سوريه يتقدم على كل الجماعات
الحكومه السوريه طلبت المفتشين الدوليين
او المراقبين الدوليين يجوا على دمشق
وصلوا لدمشق باليوم الثاني تقوم القياده
السوريه باستخدام السلاح الكيماوي على بعد
عده امتار من المفتشين الدوليين
يعني هي مهزله ومسخره
ال الحقيقه والقصه كليا تابينيه خبرك
عملتها المخابرات السعوديه بقياده بندر بن
سلطان بعد الفشل الذريع اللي وجاهدوا
القياده قياده الاخوان المسلمين في
المنطقه بقياده قطر وفشلوا بعد سنتين ونص
بعض الاجراء من قتل وتدمير والزخرفه
الاعلاميه والتزوير الاعلامي ما طلع معه
جواب الوهابيه تستلم الحرب على سوريا فاول
ما قام به عصابات ارهابيه والاجراميه من
القاعده ومن جبهه النصره ومن يحزنون ضربوا
الضربه حتى يوقعوا امريكا وحاليا امريكا
في فخ يعني معقول بالله عليك يعني كيف
تقدم عسكريا
المفتشين وبنفس اليوم يوم الوصول الى دمشق
يقوم الحكومه السوريه باستخدام
سيد سيد حبيب الى هذا الكلام الله او اولا
اولا القوى ال القوى الدوليه التي جاءت
ودخلت لمناصره الاستبداد كانت قوى ايرانيه
وقوى من حزب الله وقوى اه اه الحوثيين من
اليمن وقوع ب الفضل العباس من العراق وقوى
المالكي وبالتالي فان الضربه المفترضه
التي ستحصل اللي حصل بعد التردد الاوروبي
الكبير هي ضربه
لشرعيه الامم المتحده ضربه لل اه لاننا
نحن جزء من الشرعيه الدوليه نحن شعب يباد
نحن هناك ثمانيه ملايين في الشوارع هناك
عشره ملايين من الجياع هناك اثنين مليون
من ال من المشردين في السعوديه في ال في
في الاردن وفي تركيا وفي لبنان هناك ثلاثه
ملايين طفل بلا مدارس هناك حياه انت
اقتصاديه تفككت وانتهت هناك انهيار في كل
شيء هناك تدمير لكل المشافي والمنتجين
سيد سيد حبيب طيب كل هذا الدمار وتريد
مزيدا من الدواء دمار من امريكا ايضا انا
انا اقول لك ان الضربه جاءت لتوقف هذا
الدمار ال المحتل عندما ياتي يقوم
بالتدمير اما الذي ياتيك قاضيا ياتي بمنطق
الشرعيه الدوليه يط ياتي تكليف دولي ياتي
بتكليف من سرعه الامم انما لا ياتي محتلا
ولا ياتي ضاربا انما ياتي لوقف الضرب عن
الشعب السوري ونحن نطالب بان تاتي هذه
الضربه بكل مكوناتها واستعراضاتها وقوتها
وبكل التحالف الدولي لانها وحدها الضمانه
على ان يقف الضرب الذي عزف النشيد السوري
ونشيط حماد الديار قبل ان تبدا تبدا
المذابح وتبدا ويبدا القصف الكيماوي وقبل
ان تبدا المقابر الجماعيه كلها كلها
تحصل على على عزف النشيد السوري وعلى الى
اخره والى اخره يضعون على ما سوريا على
الجسد يدعون
شعاراتهم على الاسس ويقصفون قصفوا المباني
كشفوا البيوت قصف القرى
حرقوا المزارع قتل الماشيه ضربوه ضربوا
طالبوا المحلات التجاريه منع الصيدليات
بان تعطي الادويه اه اه اوقفوا الاطفال عن
الجهه بين المدارس ليس هناك في سوريا
مدارس كل هذا لا ياتي في في مسار سوره
انقلابيه عسكريه على نظام جاء وقد وليس
الحكم وثمه بدا بحرب شامله الشعب هذه ثوره
شعبيه بكل مكوناته
نحن نطالب بالضربه لانها الضربه التي
ستقيم ضربات بشار الاسد والا اذا انتظرنا
بدون ضربات تنفذ وتوقف ضربات بشار الاسد
فانه سيستمر في الضرب والغازات ستستمر في
الانطلاق والامم المتحده الان وفي مخازن
ال ال ال ال ال النظام اه هناك الف واكثر
من الف طن
سرير وهناك الاف الاطنان وبالتالي هو
يعتبر ان اه يعني يعني قدرته الكيماويه
يجب ان تواجه عسكريا القدره النوويه
لاسرائيل
بدا في استخدامها طيب سيد سيد
وصلت الفكره انا اسال السيد اه اجواء يعني
على موضوع يقول لك الدمار الدمار الدماء
احد الكاريكاتيرات التي تناولتها او ت ت
وزعتها يعني ال ال ال الصحف الغربيه
والعربيه في الايام الماضيه صوره لتيار
امريكي لطائره امريكيه فوق سوريا ينظر الى
الارض السوريه ويقول يخرب بيتك يا بشار
الاسد ما خلت العشرين طيب السؤال المطروح
البلد انتم تقولون لا نريد مزيدا من
الدمار وهذا السؤال اللي سالتيه لا نريد
مزيد من الدمار في سوريا لكن سوريا تدمر
هذا من جهه محمد السلمان يقول
القول بان الحرب او الضربه ستكون على
سوريا بان ال ال الضربه ستكون على سوريا
هي محض افتراء وتزوير وتكريس لمقوله سوريا
الاسد التي دفع الشعب السوري نصف مليون
ضحيه للخلاص من ها الحرب هي على نظام
العهد والمناقشه على بشار الكيماوي اما
الحرب على سوريا يقوم بها محور العمر
والمناكحه ضد سوريا منذ ثلاثين شهرا فك في
نفاقا الضربه لن تكون لسوريا يجب ان نميز
بين سوريا وبين بشار الاسد سوريا ليست
سوريا الاسد سوريا هي وطن السوريين فكيف
انا الان يخونون الجميع انت سوريا انت مع
سوريا لا احد بكامل عقله سوري بكامل عقله
يقبل ان تضرب بلده الضربه للاسد وشتان بين
الطاغيه والوطن الضربه للطاغيه ان تكون ضد
الطاغيه قمه الوطنيه اما ان تكون ضد البلد
قمه الخيانه هذه ضد الطاغيه هكذا يقول كيف
ترد يعني انا
سوري انا كمواطن شخص يتكلم عن باسم الشخصي
اتقبل كل مواطن سوري ان يكون معارضه لديه
الحق ان يكون معارضا وكل انسان سوري عنده
الحق ان يعبر عن رايه وحتى يكون معارضه
نظام وحتى يطالب باسقاط النظام
لكن من داخل سوريا باساليب وطنيه واساليب
حضاريه تحت السقف السياسي
انا قبل من كل انسان
اطلعت صنع قنابل انشطاريه
يورانيوم نبات اشتريته من ال بسوريه
العبد الفقيره امامه ما عمر يعمل فقط حكيت
اطلعت عندي زجاجات اليورانيوم
الشمس
انا قبل من كل من كل انسان عفوا من كل
انسان معارضي سوريا عنده الحق المطلق
الكامل انه يعارض بشار الاسد يعارض النظام
في سوريا طريق الحكم لكن تحت سقف الوطن
وتحت سياده سوريا ولكن انه اسمع من ابن
امي وابوي سوري عم يطلب الاستعمار عم
بينادي الاستعمار وعم بيتر جي المستعمر
اللي هو خايف اساسا يقولوا يستعمل
الله
بيت القصيد يا ابن عمي بيت القصيد سوريا
الطرفين ما بقى في
الابيض مع الوطن مع سياده سوريا مع سوريا
مع سوريا
سوريا
يعني الشعب السوري الان
كان الشعب
لو كان الشعب السوري ضد بشار الاسد مثلما
المعارضه عم تدعي ومثلما قنوات الجزيره و
مشتقاتها العربيه وغير وغيراته عم يدعوا
لو كان الشعب السوري ضد بشار الاسد كان
انتهى
كان
سيد حبيب صالح سيد حبيب صالح لماذا لا
تعلمون من التاريخ لماذا تريدون ان تاتوا
بالاستعمار الى بلدكم ايها الخونه
والعملاء كما يقول لك هو وغيره اه لماذا
لا تعلمون من العراق بس دقيقه لماذا لا
تعلمون من العراق هل يعقل ان يقبل انسان
بكامل عقله ان يضرب بلده حتى لو كان ما
كان تحت سقف الوطن تحت سقف الوطن كيف ترد
اقول هناك اولئك الذين يدعون انهم يقفون
مع النظام السوري
هم الذين جاءت بهم الدبابات الامريكيه الى
بغداد
وهم الذين ركبوها واليوم يقفون مع بشار
الاسد اليوم الذين يقفون مع بشار الاسد هم
الروس والايرانيون والحوثيون وهم
حزب الله الذي ابدا يفرز الاسلام الى الى
قسمين
الى سوريا لم ياتي احد سعودي او
البرنامج قال نص البرنامج وانت
الكلام تعليق الكلام هذا الكلام اللي
هذا كلام
الله يا الله
انا اقول لك انا اقول لك ال الذي يحصل في
داخل سوريا هو يطلب ان كل ما هو في داخل
سوريا وطنيه انا اقول كل ما حصل في داخل
سوريا هو القتل والذبح
من الطوائف في مواجهه بعضها كل ما حصل في
الداخل كان الفتنه
الضربه الامريكيه
الضرب الامريكي يجب قلت في البدايه انها
يجب ان تحصل لوقف بشار الاسد الكيماويه
ويجب ان تحصل لوقف ضربات بشار بالسكوت
والدبابات والمدفعيه وكل مختلف الاسلحه
الضربه الامريكيه تاتي لضرب اله الاسد
العسكريه ولخلق المناخات التي يستطيع بها
من يريد الهرب من يريد ان يترك الازمه
بشار الاسد من يريد ان ينشق عن نظامه من
يريد من يريد اخرين والضربه ستترك المناخي
للجيش الحر كي يبدا بعد تحرير المواقع
التي
وصلت وصلت سيد جوان
انت تقول ليس هناك سوري ولا نريد ولا نريد
اليوم تقول الامم المتحده ان اكثر من
مليون ونصف مليون سوري اصبحوا خارج سوريا
اصبحوا لاجئين
12 مليون سوري انا فقط بيته ودمرت بيوت و
ودمر مصدر رزقي مركبه صار عندك اربعطاشر
مليون ماشي هل اربعطاشر مليون اللي تشردوا
وقتلوا وضربوا بالدبابات وضربوا بالصواريخ
وضربوا بالراجمات وضربوا كل شيء له شاهدوا
الامريكي يضرب حماه الديار راح يسهل وامنه
الامريكي صاروا يقولوا السوريين الان بين
كروز وليس بالكيماوي من الذي دفع السوريين
الاستنجاد بالكروز وجدوا انه ال كروز هو
الموت الرحيم الان هو الموت الرحيم لماذا
تلوم السوريين على الاستنجاد بالشياطين
لانه شافوا الا باريس لم يترك سلاح هل
شاهدتم نظر الاطفال الاطفال الذين يموتون
وعينوا المفتوحه هل شاهدتها بتقول انه
السوريين اللي فقدوا ارزاقهم وصاروا
مهجرين وياكلون من الزباله بدون وقفوا ضد
الضربه الامريكيه من المنطقه
راح اجاوب
لكن لا لازم نفهم منك على اي سوريين عم
تحليل على ما لا مليون سوري مشرف
كل سوري عنده قيمه وتم سوريا حرام على
السوريين حتى الناس تسمع تم سوريا حرام
على سوريا على بنود المخربه المهجره من
اليها ما عم نشوف على التلفزيونات
جماعات وجماعات الوهابيين السعوديين
العصابات الوهابيه والتكفيريه والارهابيين
والمجرمين وانا معك
وانا ما
اذا كانوا
الوهابيين وهكذا دمروا لسوريا او ثلاث
اربع سوريا عشر مليون واثنين مليون لاجئ
وكسروا الاقتصاد سوريا اه
ما الذي يفعله النظام لماذا لم يحم
السوريين من هذا الارهاب الكبير الذي حلب
سوريا على مدى ثلاثين شهرا النظام الذي لا
يستطيع ان يحمي شعبه من هؤلاء الارهابيين
اللي دمر وسوريا لا يحكم سوريا انت كاسوري
تعطي ثلاثين شهر
ارهابيين
ومازالوا الارهابيين يدمرون سوريا
انت انسان ما عنده خبره عم بيتابع الاعلام
العالمي دوله في العالم اقوى دوله في
العالم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الارهاب
امريكا اش لون تمكن واربعطاشر خمسطاشر
سعودي من جماعه القاعده ينزل اقوى رمزيه
في العالم
[تصفيق]
طيب النظام الذي لا يستطيع ان من
الارهابيين
النظام القياده والجيش العربي السوري
بالمناسبه
اللي عم بيدافعوا عن الارض والعرض وكرامه
السوريين كلهم موالاه ومعارضه الجيش
السوري دافع عن ارض سوريا
سوريا
اولا الذين يقاتلون في سوريا
النظام ليس الديار
الديار قتله الشعب السوري هم الذين قتلوا
الاطفال
شردوا القرى والمدن وقطع عشرين الحياه
وحرق المشروعات وفعلوا كل شيء هؤلاء اعداء
الديار وليس
شعبهم بكل الاسلحه المخصصه للوقوف ضد
الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي لتحرير الجولان
هؤلاء الاطفال وبكره وبقروا بطون النساء
وقتلوا المواشي وقتلوا الحياه واسقطوا
براميل الدمار الشامل وضربوه ضربوا بكل
مختلف انواع الطائرات
من مدافع الميدان ثم وصل الامر الى انهم
بدؤوا بالغازات السامه والسرير وغيرها كيف
يكون حماه الديار وليس وها وقتلتها وهم
اعدائها وهم احتلوها فلياتي الاجنبي الذي
يوقف الحرب
[تصفيق]
يوقف الضرب على من يوقف الكيماوي انا اطلب
الشرعيه الدوليه
انا اطلب اصدقاء سوريا انا اطلب انا اعتبر
سوريا عضو في الامم المتحده وعليهم ان
يقوموا بالتزاماتهم تجاه في اطار قضايا
حقوق الانسان وغيرها نحن نتعرض للاباده
نحن ن تعرض للدمار نحن نتعرض الى الى حسم
عسكري يقود النظام الذي كان يدعي انه
ينتخب بنسبه تسعه وتسعين نحن نتعرض من
جمهوريه ملكيه وجمهوريه عائليه يراسها حسن
نصر الله قبل ان يراسها ايه الله الخميني
نحن نتعرض الحكم طائفه نحن نتعرض
تمارسه الاداره الروسيه والاداره العراقيه
والايرانيه كلام الدنيا كل شعوب العالم
جاؤوا الى سوريا كي يقتل الشعب السوري
ويدمروا ونحن نطلب الشرعيه الدوليه تتدخل
وهذا ليس احتلالا وليس اجنبيا انه صوت
الضمير العالمي انه صوت الشرعيه الدوليه
انه صوت الحق العالمي الاممي الذي حفظ
حقوقنا في اتفاقات جنيف
الشرعيه الدوليه نحن هذا ليس اجنبيا هذا
الاجنبي هو من قتلنا الاجنبي هو من اطلقت
الاجنبيه ومن اطلق السرير الاجنبي هو من
الايرانيين وحزب الله الاجنبي جاء الى
سوريا وكان هؤلاء التكفيريين واستحضر من
التاريخ سكينه وزينب وحجر بن عدي وقال ان
يعيد صياغه التاريخ من جديد في سوريا كان
عليه هذه الجبهه الى الجولان ويقاتل هناك
جيش العدو ولكنه لم يقاتل حيث العدو قاتلا
حيث الحماصنه والدروس والدروز والعلويين
والحماس الحلبيه و والى اخره اذا هذا هو
العدو من قلنا هو العدو ومن
هو الصديق تنتفي عنه صفه الاحتلال
وبالتالي نحن نحن لا ندعو الاخرين
الاحتلال ارضنا ندعو الاخرين
الاحتلال
الشرعيه الدوليه من المؤسسات
انت تقول انت تقول القياده السوريه هي
عماد الوطن والسوريين حولها وكذا وكذا
وكذا من يدعو الى
[تصفيق]
يا اخي انا اريد دقيقه دقيقه يا استاذ
حبيب انا عم المستوى الشخصي غير تلك
الموضوع جريده الاخبار اللبنانيه تعرفه اه
على حزب الله
وحزب الله قبل يومين تقول بالحرف الواحد
حسب مصدر مطلع في الامن العام فان عائلات
سوريه من ال مخلوف وسليمان وشاليش وشديد
وعائلات وزراء ونواب ومسؤولين ومحافظين
سابقين وحاليين سوريين عبروا خلال الساعات
الاربع والعشرين الماضيه الى لبنان عبر
نقطه المصنعه الحدوديه ولفت المصدر الى ان
معظم هذه العائلات اتجهت الى مطار بيروت
الدولي فورا لمغادره الاراضي اللبنانيه
الى اماكن اخرى هؤلاء الذين يحكمون سوريا
جديد ومخلوف وشاليش هو دينيا لم يبقى منهم
ولا واحد داخل سوريا ولو قال هذا الكلام
المعارضه كذابين ولا ستين كذابين قالته
لبنان وجريده حزب الله المتحالف مع سوريا
يعني الوطنيات وتعمل خوان ولكن القائد
الذي وعندما وطن وبين مش هذا الخائن اللي
عشرين سنه بالسجن التي سؤال صغير اخر سؤال
وجاوب على طريقه اه جواب على طريقه اه
اه
سوريا
سوريا خيانه
النظام السوري من الاسره الدوليه
عدوان
سوريا
يعني سوريا كلياتها
السؤال
المقاومه امتدادا من ايران الى سوريا الى
المقاومه الوطنيه اللبنانيه الباسله
[تصفيق]
المقاومه من ايران وسوريا وحزب الله
حبيب صالح صالح صالح
هذا الكلام سوريا صامده ولم يتحرك احد وكل
الكلام التي تقول جريده الاخبار عن هروب
كبار العائلات السوريه غير صحيح وسوريا
بشار الاسد
وطني كبير امريكا لا تستطيع ان تضرب اصلا
هؤلاء الشبيحه
ليس لهم جذور في الحياه السوريه
هؤلاء جاءوا
سلطه امر واقع هؤلاء
فتنه
بعض الطوائف
هؤلاء ليسوا سوريا سوريا هي الثوره سوريا
هي الشعب المنتشر والان في البراري
والقفار سوريا هي النساء التي
سوريا هي الاطفال الذين لا يجدون مدارس
هؤلاء هم سوريا سوريا هم الذين يقدمون في
الليل
سوريا يقول لك هذه العائله
هربوا هربوا وهم موجودون في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه
رئيس ما يتاكد ان الضربه تقع لكي يعودوا
او لا يعود هؤلاء هربوا لان ارتباطهم
بالوطن لا يسمح لهم بان يعرضوا انفسهم
ومصالحهم للخطر
هؤلاء فضلا عن انه لا يجوز ان انتقال
سوريا بالمقارنه مع هؤلاء سوريا هي شعبنا
سوريا هي ثورتنا سوريا هي الجيش الحر
سوريا هي نسائنا المسلمات هو ونساءنا
المغتصبات هم اطفالهم الذين لا يجدون
مدارس هذه سوريا سوريا التي جمعت
بالكيماوي شو شو سوريا هي التي تذكرنا
حكامها المماليك حكامها الخونه الذين
ارسلوا ارسلوا قواتهم لتحرير الكويت
وارسلوا الى العراق وارسلوا هاي لبنان
وارسلوها الى كل مكان ليس كان يتحدث عن
الممانعه الجولان على جانب درعه فلماذا لم
تشكل المحور التحالف في الجولان من اجل
اقتتال ضد اسرائيل لماذا لم تنشا المقاومه
موضوع سيد حبيب البعض يقول البعض يقول او
يردد الان مقوله القائد الاندلسي المعتمد
بن عباد الذي قال ان راي الابل عند ابن
عمي وان ظلمني اشرف مليون مره من رعي
الخنازير الامريكيه المعتديه الداعمه
للاغتصاب الاسرائيلي ل ارضنا ومقدساتنا
وانتم الان مع هذا الاخر
هذه ليست مقوله
تطبيق
هذه حكايه نحن ندعو نحن ندعو الشعوب التي
تعمل على قاعده اه على قاعده اه جنيف
وقاعده الامم المتحده وقواعد شرعه حقوق
وقاعده محبب منظمه حقوق الانسان ان تاتي
لوقف النزيف السوري وان تاتي لتفتح الشيء
علي الكيماوي الذي يضرب فيه حتى ينتهي
كما وينتهي كل الشعب السوري نحن نريد
حمايه من الشرعيه الدوليه لا نريد تنصيب
محتل ولا ندعو محتل رفض الاحتلال
[تصفيق]
ما بدي ارد عليك
ومن
ومن ومن لا لا يركع ونزيف الدم
انت لقيت
ان تبارك
الامريكي الامريكي
الامريكي
الامريكي نائب رئيس مجلس الاركان الامريكي
سابقا اليوم او ما قال شخصيا انه الضربه
المتوقعه على سوريا والهدف الاساسي لسوريا
للهجوم على سوريا معاقبه النظام السوري
الحل الكيمياوي في سوريا وانما القضاء على
القدره القتاليه
الجيش العربي السوري
لصالح كيف ترد على هذا الكلام المهم
امريكا
ولا من اجل عيون السوريين امريكا الدوليه
الاستراتيجي السوري السلاح الداخليه في
المنطقه الذي يحمي الديار
الثوره مستمره منذ سنوات لم تقدم امريكا
على اي تهديد لن تقدم فرنسا على اي تهديد
اقدموا عندما ضرب الكيماوي فلولا موضوع
القمه لما كانت هناك ضربه قادمه الكل يخاف
من استخدام هذه الاسلحه المحرمه دوليا
والتي تغطي فيها بشار الاسد كل المعايير
عندما فشل في فك الطوق حول دمشق اراد ان
وبالتالي ان نفصل بين سوريا ونظام سوريا
هي الشعب الذي يقتل
والنظام هو شيء اخر هو الذي يقتل لا يجوز
ان نتكلم عن سوريا لمعنى بها نظام الاسد
لا يجوز ان نتحدث عن معاناه سوريا ونتحدث
عن الاسد وكانهم هم قاده سوريا هؤلاء
جاءوا الى الحكم بدون شرعيه بدون انتخابات
[تصفيق]
وانا اوجه الى الجيش الحر والى طائفه والى
كل من في سوريا ان يجدوا فرصتهم في هذه
الضربه جسور في كل كل حسب موقعه
موقعه
من هذا النظام
[تصفيق]
سيد حبيب
هذه بعض المشاركات علاقه بقرار
لا تخلطوا بين سوريا والنظام ليس هناك
سوري بكامله يريد لبلده ان يضرب لكن كل
السوريين مع توجيه ضربه لمن اعاد سوريا
خمسين سنه الى الوراء المشكله وانت منهم
ان البعض مازال يعتبر ان بشار الاسد
ونظامه هو سوريا لا ابدا الخائن ليس من
يدعو الى عقاب بشار الاسد الخائن ابن
الخائن هو الذي يشد على ايدي بشار الاسد
للاجهاز على ما تبقى من سوريا يعني انت
الان بدك عن بشار الاسد
وكان ما بتقولوا دمر ما يتبقى من سوريا
الرجل يقول لك نحن لا نريد ان سوريا نحن
نريد ان نضع حدا لهذا الضمان
ثلاثين شهر
من الكذا يقول لك لا نريد ان نزيد الدمار
دمار ان نعرف
لكن
اصبح
بالنسبه
[تصفيق]
العرب
ولكن امريكا
الهجمه العسكريه
والهجوم الارهابي
اولا قياده التنظيم الاخواني
والارهابيه
على الاقل على الاقل اذا مات الشعب
بالكروز فهو لم يدفع ثمن بالعكس
[تصفيق]
الشوارع ملايين الشعب السوري لما كان
الشعب السوري صامد ولو ما كان الشعب
السوري مساند الجيش العربي السوري الباسل
وكان الرئيس
واي الشعب السوري الوطنيه السوريه
والاخلاص السوري والدفاع عن السياده
السوريه هذه سوريا من الكلام الفاضي
الطائفي الارهابي اللي عم يحكي بطريقه
خلينا نخلي السيد حبيب صالح اخيرا ماذا
تريد نحن في نهايه البرنامج الان هناك دفع
باتجاه الا تعتقد ان هذه الضربه اصلا ليس
هناك ضربه وليس هناك اي كلام انا بدي اطلع
عليك فقط مشاركه من الفيس بوك مره اخرى
دعونا نفكر منطقيا الكونغرس الامريكي
مؤسسه تخضع ل سطوه اللوبي الاسرائيلي قلبا
وقالبا هل ستعطى هذه المؤسسه للرئيس
اوباما الضوء الاخضر لضرب نظام دمشق الذي
دمر ومازال يدمر بلدا كانت تعتبره اسرائيل
خطرا كبيرا على وجودها اليس من السخف ان
يبارك الكونغرس معاقبه نظام الاسد الذى
حقق لاسرائيل من الدمار والخراب في بلاده
ما تعجز عنه في عشرات السنين لقد قال هنا
بليون ذات يوم اذا رايت جارك الذي تخشى
يدمر نفسه بنفسه فلا تقاطعه فهل الكونغرس
بهذه السذاجه ل يقاطع جار اسرائيل الذي
يدمر نفسه بنفسه طبعا من المستبعد اللهم
الا اذا وصلت اسرائيل الى اقتناع بان
الدمار الذي تريده في سوريا قد حصل ولا
باس من التخلص من قام بالمهمه بعد ان
انتهى دوره ماذا تقول باختصار
اق واقول هنا كان اللوبي الصهيوني
لو استطاع اه لو استطاع ان يدفع الولايات
المتحده بعد القصه الكيماوي الى كل الحروب
لفعل
اما الموجود في سوريا يفترض استراتيجيا
ويفترض وطنيا وعسكريا ان يكون مكرسا ضد
اسرائيل وبالتالي فلو الصهيوني يخف يوما
المستخدمه هذا الغاز ضد اسرائيل ولذلك هو
يلح
ارجو ان هذه الضربه ان تتم وارجو ان يسقط
نظام الاسد
وان يسحق الشعوبيون وان يسحق الطائفيون
وانت نصحت اجهزه المخابرات ان يسحقوا
الكلاب الذين لم يجدوا لهم دور في تاريخ
امتهم وطنهم وشعبهم وثقافتهم ومستقبلهم
تحرير ارضهم
الحوار سوريا
سيدافع الشعب السوري
العربيه السوريه
نعم
[موسيقى]